le thème de notre échec et mat ce soir
la télévision ton univers impitoyable
j'avais chanté tout à l'heure je ne
chanterai pas et pour en parler de
figures de la télévision
bruno masure christophe hondelatte alors
j'ai d'abord présenter vos d'olive
à ma gauche christophe hondelatte pour
faites entrer l'accusé alors c'est une
novélisation de votre émission pour le
quatrième tome enlèvement du baron pain
chez michel lafon se souvient s'étend de
cet enlèvement et de l'épisode macabre
du petit doit trancher enquête sur mon
assassinat bruno masure chez chiflet &
company est très bonne maison d'édition
alors je voudrais dire que moi c'est un
peu je joue pas petit bras
c'est pas un petit ans et levon ridicule
c'est un meurtre oui c'est quelque chose
d'important qui vous a assassiné je dis
bien à qui vous a assassiné à la
télévision avoir réponse dans le bouquin
donc il faut il faut le lire et puis un
bruit du soleil mais est ce que là non
je vais pas raconter saint paul à
l'intrigué est folle puisque par
définition je suis pas tout à fait mort
et puis on j'envoie ardisson et fogiel à
fleury mérogis il n'y sont pas encore ça
va venir
vous avez laissé oui mais c'est un vrai
policier et donc les les policiers
travaillent vraiment comme si on
découvrait mon cadavre
malheureusement je suis allée bon vivant
il ya les mauvais morts alors voyons
voir d'abord une présentation de vous
deux et bien justement puisque j'ai deux
figures de la télévision devant moi je
ne vais pas vous présenter et vous allez
le faire
christophe hondelatte je suis un
journaliste
redevenu à les revenus à l'étiage qui
lui convient 80% de radio sur rtl tous
les jours à midi et demi et 20% de
télévision tous les dimanches soir sur
france 2 poser comme ça je suis un
journaliste heureux voilà bah voilà
le défi il a fait bref et cours alors
moi j'ai désinformer les français
pendant 13 ans ça s'est arrêté un petit
peu brutalement donc depuis je me
consacre à mon hobby préféré l'écriture
et puis pour arrondir un peu les fins de
mois je fais quelques passes au bois de
boulogne
mais le problème c'est que les prix sont
de plus en plus bas et les tarifs
j'ai un vrai problème c'est la crise
pour tout le monde mon bon monsieur
surtout pour moi alors vous l'avez dit
vous pas vous n'avez pas évoqué vous
avez arrêté de façon brutale moi aussi
voilà les autres étant donné alors à
côté de moi petit peu ce qui s'est passé
j'ai un moment donné était emportée par
une colère et il m'a semblé que un
article qu on avait écrit sur moi était
un supporter la colère est mauvaise
conseillère
peggle donc l'arctique un article dans
libération qui abordait votre vie privée
et par l'est particulièrement de votre
fils il est décidé donc de ne pas
présenter le journal de trois là ben moi
c'était un tout petit peu plus c'était
bizarre aussi parce que moi mes patrons
bien aimé m'ont dit on te met sur le
banc de touche mais on n'a strictement
rien à te reprocher donc quelques îlots
perdra aussi on peut balancer lente et
il ya un truc un peu bizarre quand je
sais d vos patrons que c'était
albert du roy directeur de l'info et et
xavier gouyou-beauchamps pdg de la
chaîne alors je pose une question parce
qu'à chaque fois qu'un un débarquement
comme ça on y voit des visées politiques
est ce qu'il y a soyons clairs des
pressions politiques à la télévision
française sur les journalistes que vous
êtes
moi je pense que c'est plus des
pressions économiques on a vu qu'on peut
sur m6 sa capitale il peut y avoir des
pressions très fortes de deux sponsors
vous tout ça oui
politiquement je pense que ça
s'équilibre et puis je pense que deux
points de vue là la cohabitation nous a
fait grand bien parce que les pouvoirs
des uns et des autres s'exercer moi ce
que je voulais dire c'est que quand
j'étais justement sur la touche michèle
cotta qui était m'a très gentiment
proposé en dire est ce que tu veux que
j'active mais réseau pour contre foute
la paix dit moi je me surtout rien de
rien devoir à personne
moi je suis de gauche c'est jose pages
j'ai été virée sous jospin mais
franchement ça m'aurait posé problème
d'être protégé par un homme politique et
de et qu'on glisse partout masure a été
sauvé par jospin je pense que quand vous
situer politiquement la mairie déclaré
et moi tout m'intéresse partout et je
pique des colères parfois contre des
idées politiques contre des engagements
politiques des ya des choses qui ne me
plaisent pas chez les uns chez les
autres mais j'ai du mal à voter et je ne
me force pas alors moi ça fait ça c'est
un discours que j'aime pas du tout sont
mêlés je trouve qu'on a il al'avantage
de la sincérité tout à fait celle non
mais moi je les gens qui dit je vais pas
voter ça m'agace énormément parce que je
pense que c'est une conquête formidable
il ya des millions des minutes et vous
des dizaines de millions de gens sur
terre qui sur cette planète qui rêvent
de pouvoir voter et je trouve que quand
on a ce privilège il faut il faut le
faire voilà ce que je dis aux gens
qu'ils disent je vais pas voter très
bien en plus ça prend 10 minutes un
dimanche mais à ce moment là il faut
râler sur rien un autre débat qui a
actuellement est très vive c'est la
discrimination positive
vous apprenez que vous êtes débarqué de
votre poste parce qu'on veut mettre un
journaliste noir à votre place quelle
est votre réaction
christophe hondelatte et bruno masure
question de là vous pouvez appuyer sur
le petit bouton je suis j'ai toujours
été pour la discrimination positive et
je crois que il y à des époques où il
faut forcer le destin et et je dois dire
que je les gt pour avant que ça se lance
depuis que c'est en marche
ça court ça commence à m'agacer un but
pas plus tard qu'hier on m'a dit aura
probablement été le dernier journaliste
de france 2 présentateurs de journaux
blanc et mec donc on va faire on va
mettre une jeune femme voilée mais t'es
con d'avoir laissé passer ça parce que
les prochains seront des combinaisons de
discrimination positive ça ça mais ça ça
m'énerve un peu nous écouterons bazire
se forme en ce moment sur mon répondeur
jeu sur mon répondeur de messages a dit
excusez moi je suis parti je fais une
séance d'uv intensifs pour avoir la
chance de remplacer ppda l'été prochain
donc moi s'appelait alors moi ça mais
moi ça me pose problème sur bar la
discrimination positive et j'ai envie de
partir de primes de couleur de peau oui
et de revenir en quatre-vingt deux mois
j'étais donc au service politique de la
une et on a vu arriver quatre
journalistes communiste qui avait été
embauché uniquement parce qu'ils étaient
des rouges des rouges ne l'était pas de
mort il était rouge et c'était très
perturbant parce qu'ils arrivaient avec
une énorme étiquette sur le ventre et
sur le dos parti communiste français et
jeu franchement je trouve qu'en plus
c'était souvent des gens de qualité et
que pour eux et pour nous ça pose des
problèmes parce que il était là
clairement il avait été embauché pas
parce que c'était des bauges en lice
mais il est arrivé qu'ils auraient leur
étiquette et que moi je trouvais que
c'était perturbant et idem tendre harry
je le trouve très très bon et en plus il
est beau mec mais quelque part le fait
d'être embauchée pour la couleur de sa
peau c'est sur les organes en même temps
quand même
oui il ya tellement de filles cette
fille à papa à la télévision française
des noms des noms mais je sais pas il ya
une succession la faune il ya quand même
une certaine quantité de drucker échos
je ne tolère pas cette attaque
personnelle
oui non là c'est son domaine privé doit
finalement que d'autres vecteurs servent
de coups de pouce et on dit même qu'il
ya des homosexuels la télévision mais je
ne veux pas le croire
ce qui me gêne là en ce moment c'est que
le problème
il est en voie de règlement pour les
noirs manifestement voyez-vous ce que je
veux dire pour ce qui est des maghrébins
s'est pas fait ça reste à faire je sais
pas pourquoi on a décidé qu'on
commençait par les noirs d'asie
c'est à cause d'eux rachid arhab héééé
et que les maghrébins passe à la trappe
comme si un maghrébin nous a pas être
présentateur de journaux tombent et
clairement rachid arhab lillers il était
en cause
et puis bizarrement il s'est retrouvé un
peu marginalisés on agit on lui a jamais
expliqué franchement pourquoi est-ce que
vous avez vu des modifications ou une
évolution dans les domaines conviennent
invoqué dans quel sens évolue la
télévision à votre avis en ce moment
dans la tiédeur
mais je ne saurais le reprocher à la
télé parce que je crois que la télé est
un média où chaque dérapage chaque
chaque jour chaque fois qu'on lève la
voix ça prend une ampleur mais s'est
démultiplié la la télé des pales médias
de l'humeur la télé des pales médias
l'opinion
on a vite plus des tas de gens à la
télévision parce qu'ils sont un peu
sulfureux parce que parce qu'ils sentent
mauvais moi j'ai fait eu une raison vous
connaît les blés blacklisté par exemple
dieudonné par exemple voilà moi je
trouve que c'est pas normal de
blacklister de dieudonné en aucun cas
et quoi qu'ils aient fait et dieu sait
si quand il s'attaque à fogiel je le
trouve pourri dégueulasse et j'ai envie
de l'accrocher par les pieds mais mais
moi à la radio demain je l'invite non
mais c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de
frilosité mais moi je vais j'ai une
grande confiance dans l'ensemble du
corps électoral français au temps au
temps des gens quand peu appris à dire
des bêtises ça mais je pense que
globalement les gens semblent beaucoup
beaucoup plus les choses qu'on veut bien
le dire
et moi j'ai toujours été frappé je suis
un chez un ancien combattant que
en 74 on disait la télé gaulliste c'est
giscard qui a été lu en 80 on disait la
télé giscardienne c'est mitterand qui a
été élu après on disait la télé
mitterrandiste c'est chirac est élu
moi je pense que franchement les gens
sont beaucoup plus subtil qu'on veut
bien le penser et sont assez bien les
trucs pour aborder un dernier thème est
ce qu'on peut échapper
personnellement ou en général à la
peopolisation à la télévision donnent
aux mazériens moi je pense que quand on
veut on peut dire quand on est on est
pas obligé d'aller passer c'est d'aller
boire un verre au sénéquier à 11 heures
du matin à saint tropez si on n'a pas
envie d'être photographiée avec une
copine et qu'il ya des milliers de
barres en france où on peut prendre son
petit déjeuner peinard où il y aura
jamais un journaliste un photographe qui
passera moi il m'est arrivé d'aller dans
des endroits un peu glauque ou un peu
bizarre et france ô ça ne regarde que
moi et est justement mais comme
justement j'assume est totalement entre
homosexualité et dire léger jamais été
emmerdé par les paparazzis parce que
c'était pas ils s'étaient pas un scoop
cela dit il m'aurait pris en photo
j'aurais fait un procès le sait demain
gros moyens de payer l'argent facilement
la pipolisation sur ce qu'on fait elle
va avec notre métier on se ferait pas le
métier qu'on fait si on n'était pas un
peu cabot donc je suis pas d'accord mais
bon je moi ça me tentait pas cabot nom
d'abou non je je suis je cherche pas ça
du tout mais vraiment pas en tout cas
moi ça ne nous gêne pas de mettre en
scène ce que je fais et et de défendre
de manière un peu médiatisé ce que je
fais d'en faire un bond en avant de ce
qu'on est
j'ai prouvé que j'étais capable de le
défendre de manière
mais vraiment violente guy carlier quand
il a étalé son nouveau couple tellement
9 tellement encore fragile
à la une de paris match il fait
profession de même deux points de faire
la morale et il avait tenu la ligne
jusque là ils crachaient sur tous les
gens qui faisaient ça les gens qui
allaient dans voici
les gens qui allaient dans gala il
crache dessus en disant ce qui est
important c'est ce qu'on pense 1 c'est
pas c'est pas le petit minois de machin
truc est le premier truc qui fait alors
qu'ils commencent à être célèbre c'est
d'aller se fiche à la une de paris match
attendez est ce que c est ce qui en fait
la pipolisation vous invitera bien n'est
pas une sorte de bouclier de notoriété
puisque on a vu que dans la sphère harry
roselmack
on avait choisi plutôt thomass pu que sa
femme parce que sa femme est plus
connues et était donc mieux protégé est
ce qu'en fait c'est pas un mouvement
tout simplement de protection à l'égard
de la chaîne que cette peopolisation il
ya une chose qui est certaine c'est que
la chaîne vous le demande
c'est à la chaîne vous pousse à la faute
principe des attachés de presse et
qu'elles font pas le distinguo monde a
encore proposé la semaine dernière alors
qu'on s'est quand même ce que je pense
quatre pages dans voici
sans déconner pour qu'il ya encore
quelqu'un aujourd'hui qui viennent nous
proposer quatre jambes aussi c'est qu'il
arrive c'est bien c'est bien entendu la
pauvre là c'est bien là combien on va en
rester sur ses derniers mots alors comme
on dit bah vous allez fermer la
télévision élire christophe hondelatte
faites entrer l'accusé
le tome 4 leur l'évenement du baron
empain c'est chez michel lafon vous
continuer à laisser la télévision
éteinte et vous lisez et vous saurez
enfin qui a tué bruno masure en lisant
enquête sur mon assassinat
bruno masure chez chiflet & company est
une très bonne maison d'édition à tous
et merci
[Musique]